okay
Darrell if you're gonna ban people from
the Middle East can we start with the
world's number-one hypocrites Saudi
princes have moved to LA to do all the
Una's la mcstuffins back home I'd rather
of a hundred Syrian refugees next door
than Prince Abdullah bin douche bag is
that okay okay new rule since last week
it was revealed that winnie-the-pooh is
a girl not a boy
Whitney must go all the way and come out
as a lesbian come on it's obvious her
face is always buried in someone else's
honeypot
see I scared them for bowing me new role
come on come on Indonesia I realize
you're not a rich country but you know
your environmental policies are bad when
people look at this river and thing
great where am I supposed to [ __ ] now
new rule stop trying to make prostate
massage a thing
this is the new Nexus Revo prostate
massager and if you find it at all
intriguing then you're a very different
person than I am
Nexus calls it the next step in male
pleasure technology I call it a hundred
and thirty three chairs worth of no
thanks the closest I get to this is
every couple of years at the doctor's
office and not once if I thought I could
get used to this don't keep looking at
me I'm not like I'm not looking at all
new roll pizza boxes have to stop being
racist look at this cardboard hate crime
it suggests that every Italian who cooks
pizza has a mustache and dresses like
Super Mario it's 2015 high time pizza
boxes reflected the guy who actually
cooks my pizza a Mexican
and finally new rule I know the
Constitution says there can be no
religious test for holding office but
sorry you can't get your hands on the
nuclear launch codes if you own a
painting of yourself with Jesus in a
bathrobe this is a painting that hangs
in Ben Carson's home of him and Jesus
apparently enjoying a spa day
so yes you can believe whatever you want
and still run for office but it's got to
work the other way too as a voter it's
perfectly fine for me to say ah dr.
giggles because you sir are a clear and
present ding dog now we here at real
time have had our fun with ben Carson
who seems like a decent man so I try to
overlook some of his shall we say
unorthodox beliefs like the pyramids are
full of Cheerios when he said that
prison turns men gay when we all know
that's the Bravo network I had to but
now I know I am
but Ben Carson is a seventh-day
adventists a religion founded in the
19th century on pastor William Miller's
guarantee that Jesus would return to
Earth on October 22nd 1844 spoiler alert
he didn't what you think would have made
the followers go well I guess that was a
bunch of [ __ ]
it's like believing in The Wizard of Oz
after Toto pulls back the curtain but no
that's logical and this is religion
seventh-day Adventists are obsessed with
the world ending and refer to the world
not ending in 1844 as the great
disappointment they're disappointed that
the world still exists I don't have to
agree with a politician on everything we
could disagree on abortion entitlements
paid sick leave the Earned Income Tax
Credit but the earth staying is kind of
a deal-breaker for me
you know what my great disappointment is
that I live in a country where 4 out of
10 people believe we're living in end
times and that the stupid media never
asks Jesus freaks running for office 2
questions
do you believe the world is ending soon
and is that a bad thing
because I'm the opposite of an end timer
I'm a spend timer I want to spend as
much time as I can on this planet and I
want some planet left for the children
and grandchildren who are always kicking
the back of my airplanes even
politicians here love to talk about
fundamental differences this is as
fundamental as it gets folks Lamar Smith
is the chairman of the House Science
Committee and he's a Christian Scientist
which means he doesn't believe in
science he wants to repeal Obamacare and
replace it with prayer john Shimkus is
chairman of the House Subcommittee on
the environment and he says don't worry
about rising sea levels because in the
Bible God promised Noah there won't be
any more floods so what if the oceans
are dying and we kill all the fish
Christ can make more he's done it before
no wonder nothing gets done in this
country how serious can people like this
be about wanting to improve the future
when they don't think we'll be around
for it
a majority of angelical say Christ will
either probably or definitely return to
Earth by 2050 depending on his schedule
so why fix the streetlights if they're
just gonna be a big fight with Satan
why'd reform healthcare why wear pants
then Carson says he could quote feel
God's fingers pushing him to be
president you know what tell God to keep
his fingers to himself because we know
where those fingers have been in every
war in human history from the ones he
started in the Old Testament to the one
that just played out in Paris but just
in case I'm wrong about the apocalypse
and the end does come while we're off
let me make sure I say it now to all my
fellow liberals who I do really love
Mary war on Christmas and Happy Hanukkah
to all of our ages
you